pressure is building on the federal
government to declare the monkey pox
outbreak a public health emergency
according to the centers for disease
control there are now more than 5 100
cases in 47 states nationwide this week
the world health organization declared a
global health emergency as cases
worldwide surged to more than 22
thousand michael george is here with
more on the efforts to keep the disease
from spreading michael good morning dana
good morning as states asked for more
vaccines the biden administration says
780 000 doses are on the way with more
to come
so far monkeypox is disproportionately
impacting men who have sex with men but
health officials say this virus doesn't
discriminate
the lgbt community has taken the lead in
many places to bring awareness about
monkey pox in san francisco the
community put pressure on officials to
act and they did this week we are here
because we
as a city and county of san francisco
officially
are declaring a state of emergency
for a public health crisis while cases
there and across the country are on the
rise stanford's dr jorge salinas advises
caution i don't think that this is a
reason to freak out it is a public
health problem that we need to take very
seriously we need to educate our
population we need to get more vaccines
we need to get better at treating
detecting and treating patients early
there is a vaccine for monkey pox but
right now there are long lines to get a
shot because of the shortage of supplies
we are really prioritizing limited
vaccine to the populations that are most
impacted so that is including gay men
bisexual men other men who have sex with
men in the effort to meet the need a
growing number of states and cities are
prioritizing a single dose of the tudos
vaccine despite warnings from both the
fda and cdc that both doses are needed
monkey pox not to be confused with
chickenpox usually manifests with
painful lesions again it's a virus it's
a contagious disease however the amount
of exposure that you need is prolonged
you need several hours of exposure so
you're not going to get monkey pox from
going grocery shopping or going to work
every day and in labs across the nation
lessons from covid 19 testing are being
applied to turn around monkey box tests
in 24 hours or less all the same
equipment that we use for kova 19
testing we can also use for monkey pox
testing
the workflow is actually identical
and while all this may remind us of the
early days of the covid pandemic there
are some key differences monkey pox
spreads primarily through skin to skin
contact and monkey pox while serious is
rarely fatal jeff michael thank you very
much